okay so sorry about that everyone I had
some technical difficulties so I had to
stop the stream and then restart the
stream so can you guys hear me now can
you hear me now we had some technical
difficulties so I had to stop the stream
and then restart the stream but so yeah
so we want to talk about your questions
I know somebody was asking about line of
best fit and we can certainly talk about
that but I thought I would do is kick it
off with just kind of like a question
somebody was asking me this week about
typical AC T type question so let's see
shabam is saying best strategies to stay
within the time on the mass section also
can you do some examples of last ten
questions okay yeah so the more specific
that you guys and gals can be about the
questions that you want me to work on
the more help I guess I can give you so
if you're more specific like you know
ask me the exact question you want me to
work on and we can talk about that but
let's start off with this question that
somebody was asking me earlier
just recently so they were saying okay
this problem here it says you know given
5:13 its point three eight four six one
five right it says find the 180 third
digit so any idea is how you would solve
something like this so it's a repeating
decimal we want to find the hundred and
eighty third digit this is a common
problem you know on the acct math
section something similar to this where
there's like a repeating number and you
have to find out a specific digit so so
what do you think how would you how
would you address that question any
ideas okay so what do you think
well basically in a question like this
you know if you can see that there are
six digits that are repeating C three
eight four six one five so then what we
have to do is we have to say well hmm
how many times does 6 go into a hundred
and eighty-three well let's see 6 goes
into 18 three times right okay and let's
see so all right so this is zero right
with three remaining right so if you
look at that remainder what you have is
one two three okay so you can see that
that 183rd digit is actually going to be
a four so that's all you have to do is
you just have to look at you know how
many digits are repeating see how many
times it goes into that and look at the
remainder and it's like one two three so
it's going to be that number four so
yeah so that's that's one example of a
problem that you're going to see or
could possibly see on the test so yeah
so other other questions so if you guys
have some specific ones let's see yeah
so other things you guys want to talk
about so who's taking the test on Friday
anybody getting ready for the test this
Friday the acct math so what are some
other things somebody else that was on
the stream we were we were alive just a
little while ago but we had some
technical difficulties so yeah so any
specific questions you want me to work
on tonight with you guys to help you
help you do a little bit better on the
test on Friday the more specific the
better so what do you think
okay so Armando is asking about
functions so what type of questions you
have about functions Armando
piecewise functions okay so all right so
let's look at these piecewise functions
so you know sometimes they do have these
questions on the test and so basically
let's let's take a look so basically
what we have is let's do an example say
we have f of X equals x squared okay
when X is less than negative 1 and 2x
minus 3 when X is let's just say greater
than or equal to negative 1 okay
absolute value functions ok so let's do
one thing at a time so the piecewise
functions if you were going to graph
this ok what you want to do there's a
couple different ways to look at it but
you could graph y equals x squared ok
which we know is a parabola all right
and the part is that we want is only the
part where X is less than negative 1 so
if we go over here to negative 1 I can
go up to our graph we just want this
part here that's to the left or less
than negative 1 this other part we
really don't want okay so we would go
back and we would erase that okay and
then the other equation here is y equals
2x minus 3 right so our y intercept is a
negative 3 okay like that and has a
slope of 2 so up 2 over 1 we're getting
a line that looks like this right but we
only want the part where X is greater
than or equal to negative 1 so we go
over here to negative 1 equal to
negative 1 or greater okay so that means
to the right so if we were to graph this
again if I just do a little sketch down
here you can see this graph basically
going to look something like this
you're gonna have this portion of the
parabola and then you're gonna have this
portion of the line down here like that
so you can see we're on this part of the
parabola when were less than negative 1
and we're on this part of the line we're
greater than or equal to negative 1 so
yeah that's just one way to approach it
you just have to look at the restricted
domain here and graph the portion that
they're asking you okay so a good
question yeah so other things you want
to talk about other types of problems so
don't don't hesitate to chime in here
so I just wanted to say thanks to you
know all my subscribers for you know for
giving me some good suggestions for some
of the videos and just you know
participating in the channel I mean I'm
kind of learning as I go the video has
been getting better over time so I just
want to appreciate everyone for just you
know just contributing to to what it is
so so yes I'm just kind of hopping on
here I had some time I thought I would
help you guys get ready for the the
tests come come this Saturday and I
usually mention when I do these live
streams for the acct that I have a a
course that goes through it's a video
course that goes through 65 concepts to
help you boost your score you know on
the math section of the a CT so it's
called the huge a CT math review video
course 65 concepts it goes through and
you can find more about that I have a
link in the description of this video so
you can check that out but but yeah so
what other questions would you like to
talk about tonight what do you guys
think the more specific that the better
but what do you think other questions
this this is uh okay so let's see so
let's try to keep this let's try to keep
this all math related here okay
so other questions other things yeah
shabam you're right about that these
people are trying to troll troll on here
but do you have any questions anything
that I can maybe help you with what do
you think's what are some other
questions you have are you guys taking
the a CT on Saturday ok Armando is
asking how do i do parent functions and
transformations okay that's a good
question so the main thing is to
understand like what type of you know
what type of parent function you're
working with so let's look at a few
different parent functions so for
example if you have y equals x squared
okay you guys know what this parabola
this shape looks like right or if you
say for example y equals absolute value
of x you know what the basic shape of
this graph is like right and let's take
maybe one more example say for example y
equals x cubed okay you know what what
this graph looks like right okay so but
then as far as transformation goes see
any one of these equations can be
written down in a more general form so
Kenyon says thanks for breaking the math
down yeah definitely so
so what let's take this one over here y
equals x cubed you can write this in a
more general way like this y equals a
times X minus H cubed plus K so what
that H and the K do is they pick up the
graph and they shift it left and right
up and down and the a stretches the
graph or compresses the graph so for
example if we were to graph y equals 2x
minus 1 cubed plus 2 so this 2 right
here is going to shift the graph up 2
right
this one over here is going to shift the
graph right 1 okay and so what happens
we're gonna go right 1 up to we're gonna
think of that as our starting point so
instead of the origin being right here
we're gonna think of this is our origin
and then what the 2 here is going to do
is it's going to stretch the graph so
it's gonna stretch it vertically like
that so what's happening now is this
graphs going to go up a little bit more
quickly and a little bit more down a
little bit more quickly so yeah so
basically that's that's the idea is
something like that ok so you can apply
this H K and a concept to any graph
okay so Armando saying those are the
types of parent functions and
transformations I need help with yeah so
definitely so I'll show you one more
example just to kind of so we looked at
the absolute value graph up here this V
shape graph right so say for example you
wanted to graph this one negative 1/2 X
plus 2 minus 3 so you know I'm not sure
how much this is you know really
applicable to the AC T but it's good to
know in any case but basically ok shyam
is asking about matrices we'll do that
one next
ok shabam so basically this one is
shifting left to ok so left 2 minus 3 is
shifting it down 3 ok so that's kind of
like our new starting point that's like
our new vertex and then what the
negative 1/2 does you can think of this
is like the slope like you're going down
1 and right - so down 1 right - and you
can also go the other direction since
its symmetric ok and so then that's
going to be your absolute value graph
right there so H K and a alright ok but
sure mom was asking about I might be
pronouncing your name wrong so I
apologize about that
but as far as matrices go you know one
of the questions that tends to appear
sometimes on the ECT is just how to
multiply
Armondo you're welcome yeah how do you
multiply matrices so basically when
you're multiplying matrices here's the
key let me see if I can show you a quick
example here okay so here's your matrix
so you're multiplying it by another
matrix let's just say this is like 4 and
2 ok so so here's the idea so basically
what you have to do is get to figure out
what the dimensions are of this matrix
the dimensions of this matrix and then
you have to make sure that they're
compatible that you can multiply them
together so for example this one is a 2
by 2 it's a rows by columns it's two
rows by two columns
ok so 2 by 2 this one is a two rows by
one column okay and notice that those
inner dimensions match which is means
that they're compatible and you're going
to end up with a matrix that's 2 by 1
okay so the outer dimensions here so I'm
just gonna draw that out so it's a two
rows one column now this is a good
question because you can see there's a
usually one of these occasionally pops
up on the AC T so it's a tough one if
you haven't done matrices yet but so say
for example I want to find this element
right here at this top one I say well
what position is this in it's in the
first row first column so I just take
the first row times the first column so
the way we do this is we do 1 times 4 is
4 3 times 2 is 6 and then we add those
together that's 10 ok now this one here
is in the second row first column so I
take the second row times the first
column so that's negative 2 times 4
negative 8 plus 1 times 2 is 2 I add
those together negative 6 so everything
that I'm showing you here you can find
out more on my Mara's math tutor and
youtube channel you just go to Mario's
math tutoring and look up how do I
multiply you know matrices so okay so
Nasir is asking about trig identities
you know Nasir as far as a trig
identities are concerned in relation to
the the acct math the only thing that
you might see like you know is is
something like this one here is really
important to know like tangent of theta
equals sine of theta over cosine of
theta so identity just means these are
identical so as long as you know you
know just some of the basic ones like
this or say for example like cosecant of
theta is the reciprocal of sine of theta
just some of the more basic ones okay so
mom is saying arithmetic and geometric
sequences I forgot the formulas okay so
yeah so arithmetic formulas so here
let's take a look so so I'm trying to
think like okay trying to think as it
applies to like the AC T the math
section so there was a problem on one of
the practice tests a while back where it
was like somebody like you know the they
went to a job right and for example the
first day maybe they made five phone
calls and then the next day they made
like seven phone calls in nine four
and 11 phone calls and then the question
would be like well how many phone calls
did they make after like 20 days on the
job okay so this is total right so so
what do you think so how would you do
that so imagine if you made five phone
calls seven phone calls a night phone
calls 11 dot dot dot and you're
wondering like after 20 days how many
total phone calls have you made well you
know one way to do it of course is to
you know calculate all these and then
add them all up but that's a little bit
of time consuming what's another way
that we could do this using sequences in
series like somebody was asking any idea
is how you would do that using sequences
in series okay well there's a there's a
formula when it's an arithmetic series
like this and what you would do is you
would use this formula right here it's
the sum of the first term plus the last
term divided by 2 okay so the first term
here you can see is 5 right now the last
term we're gonna have to figure out what
that is and then we're gonna have to I
forgot the N over here we're gonna have
to multiply this by n so n is the number
of terms so we know that there's 20
terms we know the first term is 5 we're
trying to solve for that last term and
we're going to divide by 2 so how do we
figure out what this last term is over
here well there's another formula that
we want to know and it's this one here
it's a sub N equals a sub 1 plus D times
n minus 1 so the first term is 5 that
common difference is 2 because you can
see we're just adding 2 to get to the
next term each time and we've got 20
terms so we're trying to get to the 20th
term so n is 20 so we have 2 times 19
which is 38 plus 5 which is 43
so that 20th term is 43 so that's it so
we got it so it's 5 plus 43 is 48
divided by 2 is
24 times 20 is 480 so that'd be 480
phone calls after 20 days so that was
just one example that you might see on
that on a CT math session using that
arithmetic sequence in some formulas so
other questions I know there were some
that we're streaming past here in the in
the chat but other other questions let
me see if I can kind of go back and look
through some of these here so somebody
was asking about circumference that was
answered
daymo varus theorem we don't have to
worry about that for the acct math
arithmetic and geometric sequences okay
good so he was asking about that one
trig identities you just need to know
the basic wands let's see yeah so what
other questions what other questions you
guys have for me today are you guys
taking the a CT math or take an AC test
on on this upcoming Saturday or you're
just just studying in general
yeah so what do you guys think any
questions for me a CT math questions
what do you what do you think anybody
have anything zachary says you're taking
it saturday oh okay good and Zyliss says
I already got a 34 going for a 36 though
wow that's fantastic very good very good
so yeah so what other questions do you
have for me tonight any any questions
you guys want to go over together let me
ask you a question are you guys are you
guys studying out of some of these books
I'll show you some books here Nasir is
asking about radicals and rational
expressions you guys have this book the
official a CT prep guide this is a good
one if you don't have that one Silas
says something about Harvard there's a
Harvard one okay and let's see this one
is also a good one the real a CT prep
guide it's got practice tests in there
so those are good ones to work with if
you haven't gone through those but yeah
so what other questions what other
questions you guys want to go through so
somebody was asking about radical and
rational expressions well you know
basically there's not going to be
anything super super tricky and a CT
with regards to radicals but knowing how
to solve radical equations as important
but like so say for example like square
root of x plus 2 minus 3 equals let's
just say for example like 12 so what do
you guys think how would you solve that
radical equation there so what do you
think how would you solve that one
well you know the the key is yeah that's
right come on add three to both sides
okay so you've got 15 and this is the
square root of x plus two okay you wanna
square both sides right okay so then
you're just trying to get that variable
by itself by doing the inverse so you've
got 225
this is X plus 2 subtract 2 from both
sides
223 one thing you want to be careful of
though is that when you're solving these
radical equations is you always want to
check to make sure that you know this
answer is not an extraneous root so you
would have to take this 223 put it back
in and just make sure that it works
because sometimes you do when you're
doing this process you get a false
answer so you just want to double check
to make sure you have the right the
correct answer so yeah so what other a
CT math questions do you guys and gals
have for me tonight what do you think
anything you want me to talk about more
what mode should you mostly keep your
graphing calculator for the AC T radians
or degrees Zachary ass what do you guys
think I mean I think mainly it's in
degrees I know there's some there's a
couple of questions involved like
radians it's good to know your
conversion between degrees and radians
right but I think for the most part it's
going to be in degrees so yeah what
other questions so how did you guys find
out about the livestream are you guys
subscribers to the channel or Siobhan's
asking what were the hardest kinds of
math problems on the a CT if you know
any specifically that would help
okay Zachary says yeah okay all you got
it for through the notifications okay
what programs can we download Sujit it's
asking okay hmm that's a good question
what programs can we download so you
mean like for to have on your calculator
is that what you're talking about
well that's a good question so you know
that's a very good question actually
okay
as serious as I subscribe so ok so let
me show you a question I'll just kind of
think of something off off hand here I
know sometimes this question tricks
students say for example you have a cube
like this okay just pretend this is a
cube and say that the cube is like four
units on a side right would you know how
to find the diagonal the distance from
this corner to this corner would anybody
know how to do that and this this is
shown up on a previous test before what
do you think how would you find that
diagonal of the cube if it's four in US
on a side I mean anybody know how to do
that one shabam says I don't know hmm
it's a good question isn't it let's see
how do you get your score up I took it
one time and made a twenty on the math
which was bad I need help on the
geometry okay that's a good question
yeah so I mean I usually mentioned this
when I'm doing these live streams so I
do have a video course that's for sale I
put a link in the description to this to
this live stream it's on my it's also on
my youtube about page my Mario's math
tutoring YouTube about page but it's
called a huge a CT math review video
course and it goes through 65 concepts
and I go through a lot of problems that
show up on the you know on the tests but
yeah but yeah so for as far as this
question is concerned what you can do is
you can think about this in a couple
different ways so basically what you
have here is you want to find okay I'm
going to see if I can draw this a little
bit more accurately here so this is like
a cube right so what you want to do is
you want to find this diagonal here
first okay so if you think about this if
I look at this from from above this is
like a square right so this is like 4 4
so how much is the diagonal that square
right there anybody know that so what's
the diagonal this square that's the base
of this cube so what do you think this
is you know what makes these questions
little bit difficult is that they're
like multi-step so as you go through the
tests like the first questions you know
ok Sujit says is 4 root 2 okay excellent
that's right because this is a 45-45-90
special right triangle so that's
something that you might want to review
if you don't know you're special right
triangles
but you can also do Pythagorean theorem
also an important concept for the AC T
okay so you can see now that over here
this is for square root of two okay and
you can see this is four and you can see
we have a right triangle so now how
would we find this diagonal here from
this corner to this opposite corner this
is starting to get clear what do you
think how would you find that hypotenuse
what do you guys think well is you have
to do the Pythagorean theorem again
right so you've got a a squared plus B
squared is equal to C squared so yeah so
it's just another triangle Zachary says
okay
so let's look at this triangle here I'm
going to see if I can draw it down here
at the bottom of the page so it looks
something like this now and it says
let's see we've got 4 root 2 and we've
got 4 and so we just have to do the
Pythagorean theorem again so this will
call this side C so we have 4 squared
plus 4 root 2 squared equals C squared
and so this is what 16 plus 32 equals C
squared and you've got C squared is
equal to 48 and okay so that's good so
then we're going to take the square root
of both sides so this is a 4 square root
of 3 so that's it so you got it so
basically what it was it was like a
multi-step problem you had to find that
diagonal of the base and then we could
form another triangle and then find the
hypotenuse again so yeah so good good
questions yeah what other what other
questions you guys have for me other
things you want to work on tonight other
questions you want to go over what do
you think a CT mass so the more specific
you can be the better
I guess there's been a few trolls in
here tonight so I've been trying to kind
of kick them out as as we go through
Sujit says how can I avoid making
careless mistakes well that's a good
question you know one thing is is that
you know on the a CT you know they work
through a lot of the misses common
mistakes that students make and they'll
put those answers in the answer so just
because you see your answer in the
answers doesn't mean that that's
necessarily right so don't jump it
at first answer because you know yeah so
basically let's let's take a look
somebody else had a question in here
let's see if I can go back to that one
so Nasir is asking about trig functions
okay so necessary that's a good question
through some basic trig problems just to
see like so say for example you have
like let's just say you're flying a kite
okay like this all right there's your
kite and say for example you let out
like you probably shouldn't do this okay
you don't want to get it too high that's
yeah it could cause a problem for
airplanes and all that kind of stuff
right but basically say it's 400 feet
and you're trying to figure out like
well you know how high as a kite above
the ground if you know this angle of
elevation is let's say 50 degrees so
what trig function would allow us to
solve for the height what do you guys
think I keep saying guys but you guys in
Gales so what do you think so how would
you solve for the height which trig
functions would you use sine cosine
tangent what do you think okay so you
want to position yourself at the angle
right here okay at this vertex the 50
degrees
okay so judge says sine okay that's
right you so you've got the sine of 50
degrees equals okay good just a sine
okay good yeah that's right and so what
would it be sine of 50 equals what so
you want to really memorize this acronym
right your sohcahtoa acronym so Toa okay
so what do you think okay Amanda says H
over 400 yeah that's exactly right it's
the opposite over hypotenuse so H over
400 yeah and then all you have to do is
multiply both sides by 400 and there you
go so the height equals 400 sine of 50
degrees and sometimes I'll just leave
that as the answer right there they
won't even simplify out there to say you
know 400 sine 50 so so when you do these
problems what I usually do is I read the
you know the question real quick I
glanced at the answers just to see what
format it's in because there's no sense
in doing extra work or getting a decimal
if it's in a radical form you know so
yeah so that's an example somebody was
asking about trig functions but what
other questions do you guys have so what
do you think other questions you have
for the AC T whoo so I know some people
are just how do you graph a piecewise
function Oh Tyler go back in the last
room we graph one earlier this evening
so check that out just go love it go
back a little ways we talked about that
so other questions you guys have for me
is I Alyssa's question can you
completing the square example yeah so if
I missed your question just feel free to
ask it to me again I sometimes I'm when
I'm working I don't see all the
different you know I did different
problems here now completing the square
you don't really need to know completing
the square for the enough to do
completing the square for for the a CT
math so you don't have to worry about
that okay so other questions that you
guys want to talk about tonight what do
you think a CT math questions what do
you think so we're just trying to focus
on the a CT math right now so what do
you guys think other questions you have
for me Sujit says oh how should I pace
myself okay that's a good question so
basically you know you want to go
obviously quicker in the beginning
because the questions are easier in the
beginning and then you know you want to
save some time for some of those more
difficult multi-step problems near the
end of the test so yeah I mean basically
you have 60 minutes okay and you know
you there's 60 questions so it's about a
minute a question but you know maybe the
first questions at the beginning might
only take you like you know maybe like
20 seconds and then you can save some of
that time for some of the tougher
problems later on so yeah you know what
I would do is I take some practice tests
on your own and just kind of you know
kind of see how your pacing is if you
know if you're not finishing in time you
might want to pick it up a little bit
you know but obviously you know it's
to get the questions right than to try
to go too fast and miss a lot of them -
so Siobhan was asking what I want are
some of the most common types of math
questions on the a CT okay that's a good
question man I wish you had gone live a
little earlier I didn't my test last
week and fail that Oh No okay what about
trig equations oh we just didn't want we
just did a a sohcahtoa want a sine one
yeah so yeah other questions you guys
have the more specific you can be the
better
but what do you think other questions
have you guys taking some practice tests
yeah what do you think other questions
you guys want to go over so we did some
sine cosine tangent questions what else
yeah let's see
well you know if you guys want I don't
know if you're interested in this but
you can check it out it's just go over
to to the description in the in this
livestream I've got three free previews
so three free lessons for the a CT math
and I also have another courses for the
the SAT and I've got three additional
lessons that are free in that course as
well so if you want to just get started
and just get some get some help going on
the a CT and a CT just check out those
two courses my huge a CT math review
video course and my huge SAT math review
video course and you know that'll get
you started going over some some
important concepts that you want to know
you know for the test but uh yeah other
questions you guys want to talk about
we've been streaming for about a half an
hour so now we had a little technical
difficulties in the beginning but Tyler
says we won't let me go back yeah it's
possible that it's processing right now
of Tyler so it should should let you in
a little bit here okay now Sears saying
can you help with unit circle
unit circle is not a really big part of
the you know the a CT but you can go to
my channel this year and I've got videos
on how to master the unit circle so
that's under my Mara's math tutor and
YouTube channel
but yeah so other other a CT questions
you guys want to talk about a CT math
what do you think what do you think oh
okay here we go
so Jacquelyn saying can you go over logs
okay yeah let's talk about logs okay so
alright so when you talk about logs
there's not like a lot as far as blogs
on the a CT and just says how it
equations that results in one real
solution or no solution okay we'll talk
about those to Jess okay good question
but as far as long as like say for
example you have log base 3 of 9 so the
most important thing is really knowing
how to convert from the logarithmic form
to the exponential form and here's the
thing that you want to remember that
logs and exponential functions that are
inverses of each other right just like
adding and subtracting multiplying
dividing squaring and square rooting so
if you've got the log base 3 what you
can do is you can exponentially
okay arrays both sides using base 3
because exponential functions and
logarithmic functions are inverses as
long as the bases are the same so now
all we have to do is figure this out
with 3 to what power is 9 that's 3 to
the second power so this whole thing
equals 2 I'll show you one more example
like this is probably the most common
type of a log question it's just just
knowing how to switch forms so say for
example you had log base 10 of 100 what
does that equal anybody know if this one
is log base 10 of 1 100th what do you
think well by the way if you if you guys
are enjoying this live stream if you you
know wouldn't mind giving me a thumbs up
that'd be great
or if you don't like it give me a thumbs
down that's that's fine to just give me
some feedback and Abdullah's saying
negative to okay what do you think is
you right and if you haven't subscribed
to the channel my mario's math tutor
youtube channel yet go ahead and
subscribe to that so yeah so basically
you're right so Abdul is right so you're
going to exponentiate both sides you've
got 10 to what power is equal to 1 over
100 so that's going to be negative 2 so
the whole thing is just going to be
negative 2 yep just your right negative
2 good all right so you guys are asking
good questions now just was asking about
questions where there's like one
solution or no solution okay so let's
look at some of those all right so yeah
so what I'm going to show you some
examples so let's say for example if you
had something like this like 2 times X
minus 3 is less than 3x let's say plus 5
minus X okay so I'm just this is up
actually a problem that you could see on
a CT okay it's working with inequalities
and what I would do is it's just like
solving an equation so we're going to do
the distributive property we're going to
simplify both sides 3x and negative 1x
is 2x right now if we subtract 2x from
both sides what do you notice we get
negative 6 is less than 5 now you see
how the variables cancelling out on both
sides all we're left with is negative
is less than five so what does that tell
you so just what do you think our
variable dropped out here what do you
think negative six is less than five is
that one solution is that you know
infinite solutions or is that no
solution what do you think negative six
is less than five well first of all we
have to analyze this is true is negative
six less than five yes that's true so
Sujit says it's infinite solutions
you're absolutely right
now if it was the other way if it was
negative six is greater than five you
say well that's that can never be right
that's false and then this would be no
solution right okay so that so what
happens if your variable cancels out on
both sides like that then you just have
to analyze what's left say is that
always true or is it never true if it's
always true it's infinite if it's never
true then it's you know no solution so I
hope that answers your question just a
little bit better but what were some of
the other questions let me go back a
little bit yeah so so we went over some
of the yeah so other questions you guys
have what do you think what are the best
websites to get practice tests you know
that's a good question if you you know
if you go to Google okay at Google
search and if you just type in you know
free a CT math you know PDF you know
like that there I can't remember the
name of the site but there's a site
that'll come up and it'll bring you up
some free printable like past a CT test
I think there's about five of them on
this particular site I can't remember
the site name and you could print those
off and you could practice with them but
you know these books here that I kind of
showed you earlier these are excellent
too these are you know formally released
tests by the a CT that real a CT prep
bad that's a good one and then of course
you can check out the official a CT prep
guide this one over here this is the
2016-2017 but there's a new one out now
but those are just old tests that they
release so but it's good to practice
because it's the understanding those
underlying concepts okay so other
questions that other questions that you
have I know some some questions where
maybe
got by me here a little bit but let's
see what do you think so I'm trying to
pick out the ones that are better you
know more likely to be seen on the
upcoming test here so what do you think
other questions other things you want to
ask me can you do a lot problem with
variables yeah though you know with the
Sujit that's a good question that you
can go into my um you know what if
you're interested in log sujet go to my
channel Mario's math tutoring and look
up a logs everything everything you need
to know ok so if you go to logs
everything you need to know it's like 20
minute video goes through all different
kinds of problems on logs so yeah I'd
probably that would probably help you
the most
so yes so let's see other questions
other things you guys want to ask me
about a CT math yeah so if you haven't
checked it out already you know check
out my my huge a CT math review video
course it goes through 65 concepts
underlying concepts and then we go
through example problems using those
concepts that they want you to know when
you take the test so you can see the
link in the description to this live
stream it's it's got the link there and
you can check out three free lessons so
you can see if you know that helps you
out if you want to learn more you can
get the other course so that's for sale
Nasir is asking what's a conic that's
not really something you know for the
acct but you know conic just means cone
and so like say you had like two columns
and end like this right and a conic
section is like so you take like a plain
a flat surface and you cut through it so
depending on where you cut through like
if you cut through it like this you get
a circle but if you cut through it on an
angle you know you'd get like a like a
parabola like this say so if you cut
right through this point right here you
just get a point if you cut right
through around this diagonal you just
get like a line so okay so if I'm saying
at how many points to the graphs of x
squared plus y squared equals 9 and XY
equals three intersect okay let me see
if I can write that one down shabam so x
squared plus y squared that's a practice
question okay good
her plus y squared equals nine and the
other one is XY equals three okay
there's a couple different ways to do
this problem okay one way is graphically
okay so if you realize this is the
equation of a circle and by the way
that's that's a hint you really want to
know your equations of circles so they
always seem to have one question about
that but the radius is three for this
circle so one two three one two three
right okay and so you can see there's
your circle right like that
okay now this one over here this is
really like y equals three divided by X
okay this is actually a hyperbola and so
if we graph this one like say for
example if X is a 1 right y would be 3
so you'd be you're like right there and
say X is 3 y would be one you'd be right
about there so it looks like now if you
do negative it's gonna you know some
negative values Cooksley can go like
this now it's possible to could cross it
you know these two points right here or
maybe this came down a little bit lower
across it like four points or it might
cross that none so it's really hard to
tell from the graph so what I would do
is I would do a substitution I would say
if y equals 3 over X I would put that in
place of Y right there okay so let's see
if we can take this one step further
here so basically what we have is we've
got x squared plus instead of y we're
gonna put 3 over X in place of Y right
Jacqueline says our matrix questions
common usually there's only like maybe
one on there you know if at all and it's
basically knowing how to maybe like add
matrices subtract and multiply
nothing too complicated I've got a video
about I've got a few videos about
matrices on my wireless math tutor
YouTube channel if you want to check
those out you can see those there so
this is like 9 over x squared ok can you
help me understand algebraic expressions
yeah we can talk a little bit about that
ok now what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to multiply through by x squared
okay like this so I get X to the 4th
plus 9 equals 9 x squared right
I'm gonna get everything on one side set
it to zero right so then we can see if
we can factor this so is this factorable
oh this is this is a tough question so
this is let's see is it factorable no
see it's not really this is not
factorable so this is a tougher question
but hmm what we could do is we could
think about this instead of as X to the
4th minus 9 x squared plus 9 let's just
think of this as x squared minus 9 X
plus 9 okay and what I'm what I'm going
to do is I'm going to use the
discriminate so remember the
discriminant is a b squared minus 4ac so
this is a is 1 B is negative 9 C is 9 so
we get a 81 minus 4 times 1 times 9 now
see how this comes out too yeah so
basically you have to check to see if
they're going to be real or imaginary
though that's the thing Shabab so yeah
it's going to be 81 minus 36 so see how
this is greater than 0 so that means
that you're gonna have two real
solutions now that's if it was a you
know if that was x squared so yeah this
is actually going to have 4 4 solutions
so when I drew that graph it wasn't a
super it wasn't a super good but it
looks like it's actually gonna cross
like that and like that but the thing is
is you can use your you can use a
calculator like this on the test right
so so why did I multiply by x squared oh
I was just trying to clear the
denominators up here I was just trying
to clear the denominator see how the X
Squared's in the bottom so I was just
trying to put it into like a little more
friendly form so but yeah then I was
just kind of analyzing it like as if it
was a quadratic and then I was doing
that discriminant to see how many
solutions there were but yeah I was
gonna say another way to do it is you
could graph it you know on your
calculator and look for those points of
intersection that's another option but
yeah other questions other things you
want to talk about what do you guys
think other questions I might be able to
help you with so it sounds like some
people are just are doing really well
they just need to get a couple extra
points to get a perfect score and then
other students are just trying to try to
boost their scores up a little bit
higher so but yeah what other what other
questions do you want to ask me about
here
hmm what if the discriminant
then it means that you'd have two
imaginary solutions or or no real
solutions
so yeah the discriminant is good to know
for the test but yeah if it's equal to
zero you get one real if it's less than
zero then you get two imaginary or you
could say no real if it's greater than
zero you get a two real yeah so that's a
discriminant yeah you can find out more
about these concepts on my channel if
you cruise on over there just look up
discriminate Mars math tutoring and I'll
tell you a lot more probably than you
know then there's like little brief
intro here but yeah so other questions
anything else you want to ask about
where it's getting late I know people it
probably depends on where you are in the
world I guess but other questions you
want to ask me reciprocal function ok
Shabab sure mom's like I've got a bunch
of good questions for us tonight that's
great yeah reciprocal functions are like
this like cosecant of X this is the same
as 1 over sine of X see how these are
reciprocals of each other or like secant
of X equals like 1 over cosine of X
right or tangent of X is like 1 over
cotangent of X you know so sine and
cosecant are reciprocals cosine and
secant are reciprocals tangent and
cotangent are reciprocals so yeah so I
hope that answers your question on that
one other questions so if you guys like
this content and you want more you know
math help like this you know feel free
to subscribe to the channel check out
more videos on my Mario's math tutoring
YouTube channel and you know that's
that's a good way to get some some real
help I dig deeper into each concept you
know more than we are on this livestream
I'm just trying to answer some quick
questions I'm trying to hopefully help
students for that you know upcoming a CT
for the Saturday but I know everybody's
kind of on a different time schedule so
how would you graph a trig function yeah
that's that's a more general question
this year but
you can find all about graphing sine and
cosine on my youtube channel or graphing
tangent cotangent okay all right we'll
see you later shabam thanks for
participating in the live stream
appreciate you having you here so well I
think let's see any other questions what
do you think there's about ten people
hang hanging on here just trying to pick
up some some pointers but what do you
think anybody else want to ask a
question about the acct math for
Saturday so if you go over to my channel
I've got some past live streams on there
you might get some benefit from those
you might want to check those out I've
also got like a playlist is called a CT
math concepts and you might get some
benefit from that and then probably my
most popular video to date is a video
it's called if you haven't watched this
one it's really good it's called AC no
it what's it call is called a CT math 21
concepts okay to boost your score okay
so if you look up that if you look up
that video that's a free video it's on
YouTube it's also on my channel
it's a CT math 21 concepts to boost your
score and it's about I think it's 49
minutes long but it goes through 21 key
concepts that really help you where as
you know my video course that I sell its
65 concepts so I go through more
concepts and I go deeper into the
concepts but if you're just looking to
kind of see what it's a lot you know
maybe just kind of get some you know
quick free help I would check out this
video here it's like I said I think
about it's almost up to 80,000 views
right now so a lot of people have
benefited from that so it's helped them
on the test so I would start here and
maybe check they check the course check
the free previews and then you know that
you can always check some more live
streams and some more info on my on my
youtube channel but yeah so I think
we're gonna wrap it up for tonight so
everybody thanks for participating and I
appreciate it and I look forward to
helping you with your math and I hope
you do well on the test feel free to
report back and let me know how you did
just give a few shout outs here
Sujit thanks for participating okay
and Arjen okay thanks for thanks for
being part of the the chat and this year
thanks for being here appreciate you all
your input and Jacqueline thanks Lee
thanks again for joining edge Siobhan
okay who else is on here tonight see we
had a lot of good participation that was
great just had some good questions do
Lola's in here helping out very good
yeah all right great well thanks again I
look forward to helping you guys through
my channel feel free to reach out to me
anytime you can send me a youtube
comment or whatever and I look forward
to finding out how you guys did on the
tests okay so I'll talk to you later and
see you next time bye